and the news of course that nobody
wanted to hear
that martin that
so david amos has died after being
stabbed
at his constituency surgery this
afternoon
yes dreadful news um
and i think that there were
pretty clear indications in the last
hour as soon as this news broke that um
this was a very very serious stabbing
there were reports that sir david had
been stabbed
several times
and
one witness
albeit secondhand had
described a woman
running out of the surgery screaming on
the phone that somebody had been stabbed
and that he wasn't breathing
and given sir david's age 69
i think it
it didn't look terribly promising
those early reports but now confirmation
from essex police
that um sir david uh has that well
ethics police confirming that a man has
died but um but we do know that it is
um so david amos
um the police said that when they got
there he wasn't breathing
um and uh
he wasn't breathing and he died
at the scene um in the last few minutes
witnesses have talked about the air
ambulance leaving
um the scene and clearly
her paramedics
spent a good deal of time
trying to save for david's life we know
that police were called just after
midday
another witness had
talked about seeing
so david 20 minutes before that so
about quarter to midday he'd been
outside
the surgery um greeting people
um
and then within a few minutes
this terrible
stabbing murder
now had um had happened
uh a man's in custody a 25 year old man
um
police will have four days in which to
uh to question him there's no indication
at this stage of course
of any motive um for the attack
but mps are never more vulnerable than
they are
on a friday when they
uh to a man and woman um
hold their local surgeries
where they make themselves available to
anybody um within their constituency who
wants to talk to them about any kind of
issue um you know for david like his
colleagues
spends most of his time
at wence westminster where they are
where mps are protected
um to a to a massive degree but of
course once they
leave westminster and go back to their
constituencies particularly mp's back
bench mp's fight for david
they do become more vulnerable and their
surgeries they really don't know who is
going to turn up but they don't want to
be seen
as remote figures hiding behind a big
protective shield